[Musique]
bonjour à tous et bienvenue sur LCP dans
question d'actualité très heureuse de
vous retrouver ici Salle des pas perdue
on est à quelques mètres de la salle des
quatre colonnes quelques mètres de
l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée nationale où
vont avoir lieu tout à l'heure les
questions au Gouvernement une séance que
vous allez pouvoir suivre en direct et
en intégralité sur LCP alors avant
dernière séance ici à l'Assemblée
nationale l'assemblée qui espère boucler
ses travaux le 23 juillet en effet la
Conférence des Présidents a ouvert la
session pour que les députés puissent
siéger ce week-end là des 22 et 23
juillet pourquoi parce qu'il faut le
temps de légiférer sur le projet de loi
de reconstruction d'urgence annoncée la
semaine dernière par le Président de la
République suite aux émeutes urbaines la
séance ordinaire elle reprendra comme
d'habitude début octobre première séance
Lundi 2 octobre mais une session
extraordinaire n'est toutefois pas
exclue en septembre alors on va parler
de cette actualité parlementaire
aujourd'hui avec Elsa mon ningava
Stéphanie des pierres qui se trouvent
salle des quatre colonnes nous
retrouvons également Marco pommier
toujours dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale pour le menu des questions au
gouvernement et puis nous vous ferons
vivre l'arrivée de la première ministre
et des membres du gouvernement ce sera
cours d'honneur l'entrée principale du
palais Bourbon aux alentours de 14h45
14h50 elles amont un Gava vous êtes vous
seul des quatre colonnes quel est
l'ambiance ce mardi avant dernière
séance je le disais avant la coupure et
ben justement on parle beaucoup de ce
programme de cession extraordinaire
Brigitte puisque vous l'avez dit
programme charger il faut finir le
projet de loi sur la justice il faut
aussi entamer celui sur l'industrie
verte et puis le projet de loi de
reconstruction projet de loi d'urgence
il aurait donc peu de jours mais
beaucoup de textes à étudier les députés
veulent absolument débattre de chacun
des textes mais tout le monde a en ligne
de mire évidemment et bien la pose
estivale
on retrouve Marco pommier maintenant qui
lui est dans les tribunes de l'hémicycle
de l'Assemblée nationale Marco quel sera
le thème principal de ces questions cet
après-midi
écoutez Brigitte il n'y a pas un thème
mais plusieurs sujets qui vont s'imposer
dans l'hémicycle d'abord l'influence des
réseaux sociaux dans la propagation des
violences urbaines fin juin au moins
trois questions cet après-midi sur ce
sujet trois questions aussi sur la
manifestation du week-end dernier en
mémoire d'Adama Traoré décédé en 2016
après une interpellation des gendarmes à
samedi 2000 personnes se sont
rassemblées à Paris donc plusieurs
députés de la France insoumise et des
écologistes malgré l'interdiction du
rassemblement elle les insoumis
justement interpelleront le gouvernement
sur la bravenne à cette unité de police
à moto de nouveau mise en cause pour des
violences en marge de se rassemblement
une enquête administrative a d'ailleurs
été ouverte
merci Marco pommier on vous retrouvera
un petit peu plus tard dans cette
émission pour le menu complet des
questions au Gouvernement j'accueille à
présent sur ce plateau Erwan balade en
bonjour et merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes députés démocrate du Finistère et
Cécile Hunter Mayer bonjour merci d'être
là vous êtes député socialiste et à
parenté de la Saône-et-Loire alors on va
parler du projet de loi justice qui est
à l'examen en première lecture ici à
l'Assemblée nationale et après être
passé déjà une première fois au Sénat
Stéphanie Despierres vous êtes salle des
quatre colonnes c'est un texte important
avec surtout un budget historique c'est
une hausse sans précédent selon les mots
du ministre Éric Dupond-Moretti pour une
justice plus efficace et plus rapide
comme en 2020 de le budget augmente
cette année encore 9,6 milliards d'euros
en 2023 et cela va continuer jusqu'à la
fin du quinquennat il atteindra les 10,8
milliards d'euros en 2027 cet argent
servira d'abord à recruter du personnel
10 000 personnes dont 1500 magistrats
tout autant de greffiers l'objectif
final du gouvernement et de diviser par
deux les délais de justice d'ici 2027 et
puis le texte prévoit aussi le
renforcement le recrutement pardon de
surveillance de prison et la
construction de 15000 places
supplémentaires c'est la concrétisation
d'une promesse d'Emmanuel Macron merci
Stéphanie Despierre alors Cécile Hunter
c'est un budget qui est en hausse de 8%
qui a pour but d'atteindre les 10
milliards 8 en 2027 est-ce que ça c'est
pas l'argument principal pour que la
gauche puisse le voter c'est un argument
qui compte beaucoup je partage
effectivement cette analyse et je ne
dénie pas l'effort financier extrêmement
important d'une justice qui en a
vraiment besoin et je dirais que la
démocratie elle vit avec un pilier aussi
qui est celui de la justice et si la
justice se fragilise et se clochardise
comme l'on dit de précédent garde des
sauts en particulier Jean-Jacques urbuha
c'est bien nous accueillons de manière
tout à fait intéressé
et satisfaite cette augmentation je
voudrais simplement ajouter que c'est un
affichage important indiscutablement en
revanche il faut que cette affichage
trouve sa transformation dans la loi
dans les lois de finance qui viendront
et nous y veillerons mais c'est
affichage nous permet et bien de darguer
lors des lois de finances de la
nécessité de mettre les crédits à la
hauteur de ceux qui sont prévus à
l'article 1er alors Erwan Balan
Stéphanie Despierre a un petit peu parlé
de ces de ses moyens mais qu'allez-vous
faire de toute cette argent alors on
sait qu'il y aura des greffiers des
magistrats supplémentaires mais est-ce
que vous pouvez nous détailler pourquoi
faire finalement des moyens humains
supplémentaires ce qui ce qui est
important parce que aujourd'hui vous
l'avez dit on veut accélérer les délais
dans la justice c'est un des principales
reproches que que fait les Français ce
que font les Français sur sur la justice
c'est qu'elle est trop lente et pour
qu'elle aille plus vite et qu'elle
fonctionne mieux il faut des moyens
humains donc magistrats 1500 greffiers
c'est inédit c'est énorme et puis en
tout dix mille personnes pour 10000
personnes des auxiliaires de justice ou
tout le la chaîne globale de la justice
pour qu'elle fonctionne mieux
c'est un mouvement qu'on a commencé il y
a 5 ans et qu'on va encore continuer
pendant 4 ans et en disant on aura
réarmé la justice de notre pays est-ce
que ça sera suffisant je pense qu'il
faudra continuer donc c'est pas les
chances 2027 les effets se poursuivront
jusqu'à 2027 et j'espère qu'on
continuera après parce que la justice
dans un pays et Cécile Mayer vient de le
dire dans une grande démocratie c'est un
des piliers c'est un des fondamentaux
d'une grande démocratie donc voilà des
moyens supplémentaires mais aussi un
certain nombre de réformes nécessaires
pour être dans l'air du temps et dans et
dans la préoccupation d'un certain
nombre d'heures et revenir bien sûr mais
vous avez entendu un Juan Balanant
l'objectif finalement c'est de diviser
par deux les délais de la justice est-ce
que vous y croyez quand vous voyez tous
les moyens qui sont mis sur la table
écoutez il faut ensuite transformer les
faits et je pense que de toute façon les
scènes ne peut être transformé que si on
a mis de l'argent sur la table ça c'est
clair donc c'est une condition qui est
nécessaire est-ce qu'elle est suffisante
je ne pense pas il faudra toujours la
vigilance en fait ça veut dire qu'il
faudra peut-être aussi un suivi
parlementaire il faut bien sûr il faut
un suivi parlementaire d'une loi de
programmation aussi importante que
celle-ci
je pense en particulier au personnel de
juridiction qui croit beaucoup quand
même à un soulagement dans leur tâches
et qui voit dans l'affichage de 10000
créations de poste
enfin peut-être une forme de bout du
tunnel ou leur travail est simplifié
parce que les délais dont on parlait
Erwan Balanant c'est un sujet majeur qui
pèse beaucoup sur le justiciable qui
croit plus en la justice mais aussi
beaucoup sur le personnel qui ne croit
plus non plus en son travail donc il y a
une perte de sens du métier de juge ou
de métier de greffier et il nous semble
qu'il faut effectivement remettre au
coeur de l'ouvrage cette question d'un
délai parce que c'est me semble-t-il
consubstantiel à une bonne décision de
justice et puis mettre le juge au coeur
du litige donc vous vous dites c'est
possible mais avoir effectivement le
déploiement de tous ces moyens c'est
vrai qu'il y a beaucoup de moyens qui
sont qui sont mobilisés mais c'est aussi
souvent un problème d'organisation
est-ce que ces moyens seront
véritablement bien fléchés et bien
utilisé surtout à un moment donné quand
vous avez pas les moyens ça s'engorge et
ça symbolise et c'est ça qu'il faut
combattre quand on visite et avec Cécile
Hunter Mayer je sais qu'on le fait nos
juridictions il vous disent nous
l'urgence on sait faire c'est c'est dès
qu'on est dans des contentieux qui
sait pas qui nous demande pas des délais
c'est là que que tout symbolise et c'est
là qu'il y a des retards qui se prennent
et ça c'est pas tolérable parce que
c'est intolérable pour des Français qui
sont en attente d'une décision qui soit
victime ou qui soit auteur il faut que
ça aille plus vite et vraiment si on met
le paquet si on organise bien on va
réussir à gérer ce qu'on appelle un
terme un peu barbare le stock pour avoir
ensuite un flux continu et pour
rattraper le retard qu'on a eu et c'est
tout l'ambition depuis maintenant 6 ans
et c'est cette ambition qu'il faut avoir
et qu'il faut continuer mais ça passe
aussi par des ajustements sur la manière
de faire et par exemple alors c'est pas
dans le texte parce que c'est du
réglementaire mais sur la question
civile il va falloir revoir aussi la
façon dont on juge les affaires civiles
pour mettre plus de place à la médiation
plus de place à l'accord entre les
parties pour que parfois ça aille tout
simplement plus vite et dans moins de de
moins de contentieux et dans moins de
conflits entre les parties qui soient
victimes ou auteurs alors on va
retrouver à présent Olivier Marleix qui
est président du groupe les républicains
il est à vos côtés elles amont d'un Gava
Stéphanie Despierres il est à vos côtés
Stéphanie alors comment les républicains
voient ce projet de loi justice
qu'est-ce qui vous convient ou qu'est-ce
qui ne vous convient pas dans ce projet
de loi sur la justice l'essentiel du
débat je pense qu'on aura sur la
question des plages de prison parce
qu'en réalité le problème dans notre
pays aujourd'hui c'est que toute la
toute la réponse pénale et sa fermeté
éventuelle est conditionnée par la
disponibilité du nombre de places de
prison puisqu'il y a pas assez de place
de prison dans notre pays et bien les
juges évitent de condamner à des tests
de prison donc c'est une aberration il
faut en sortir si on veut rétablir de
l'autorité si on veut plus de fermeté
dans la réponse pénale il faut plus de
disponibilités en prison le gouvernement
prévoit 15000 places supplémentaires
d'ici 2027 c'est insuffisant pour vous
oui c'est suffisant parce qu'en réalité
quand on met ça au bout du aujourd'hui
il y a 62000 places on sera à 77000
places au bout de ce plan aujourd'hui on
a déjà 74 000 détenus c'est pas assez
j'aurais rappelé surtout quand même que
que depuis 10 ans on a construit très
peu de place de prison sunnisque d'un
Sarkozy on a livré 7000 places de prison
supplémentaires sous François Hollande
1380 je suis Emmanuel Macron à peine
1900 donc on a aujourd'hui on a on
affaibli on a tardé à construire des
places de prison d'où cette réponse
pénale trop faible trop souvent vous
pourriez ne pas voter un projet de loi
qui augmente les places de prison
renforce les moyens de la justice pour
l'instant
renforcer on veut des objectifs plus
importants effectivement aujourd'hui le
gouvernement est assez peu volontaire on
voudrait aussi des engagements un peu
plus ferme de la part du garde des
sceaux sur les moyens de la de la
réponse pénale face aux face au mineur
là aussi ce Nicolas Sarkozy on a
inauguré 6 établissements pénitentiaires
pour mineurs les seuls établissements
pour mineurs qui existent aujourd'hui
sont des établissements qui ont été
construits sous la droite depuis pas de
mise en chantier et donc là aussi on
avait à l'époque est centre éducatif
fermé il y a plus de volonté d'en ouvrir
donc on amènera aussi le garde des
sceaux à prendre des engagements sur ce
sujet là pour nous c'est vraiment des
conditions sine économes merci et le
projet le débat de justice prolonge
toute cette semaine
erwanant vous avez entendu Olivier
marlex il dit ça va pas assez loin sur
la création de place de prison vous en
prévoyez 15000 aujourd'hui il y a 60 000
détenus 73000 détenus et 60 000 places
effectivement il y a cette surpopulation
carcérale et ce qu'il faut pas aller
au-delà alors 15000 c'est déjà un
chiffre important et c'est un chiffre
qui va faire tenir ça va pas toujours
être simple parce que vous n'avez pas
tenu déjà l'objectif sur le premier
quinquennat
dans certaines dans certains territoires
et je pense par exemple à
l'Île-de-France ou vous avez des
positions de l'exécutif régional qui qui
n'encourage pas et qui n'incite pas à
trouver des solutions donc premier point
après
ce que dit Olivier Marleix n'est pas
tout à fait vrai la justice c'est pas
que la question des prisons la justice
c'est d'abord des magistrats et des
greffiers tout un personnel judiciaire
en capacité de donner des réponses et de
donner des réponses pénales et cette
idée qui est fausse de croire que on est
une justice laxiste parce qu'il y aurait
pas assez de place de prison c'est
complètement faux c'est pas pour ça et
déjà on n'est pas pour régler la
surpopulation il y a deux il y a deux
sujets il faut régler la population
pour régler cette question tout
simplement parce que vous avez aussi des
questions de dignité humaine à
l'intérieur des prisons et d'échec de la
réinsertion parce que si vous êtes
détenu dans des conditions qui sont pas
des conditions dignes et qui sont pas
des conditions d'humanité vous n'avez
aucune chance de vous réinsérer à
l'issue de votre peine la prison c'est
pas une condamnation à vie pour les gens
qui sont condamnés c'est une
condamnation pour payer à la société le
mal qu'ils ont pu faire le mal qu'ils
ont pu faire à des victimes mais aussi
préparer la suite et préparer la
réinsertion les gens qui sont en
récidive c'est de la double peine pour
tout le monde et donc c'est un sujet et
si on fait 15000 places de la prison
c'est tout simplement pour avoir des
établissements qui sont dignes qui sont
corrects mais à côté de ça il faut aussi
travailler sur un certain nombre de
sujets d'alternatives à la peine et
c'est ce qui avait dans notre texte
parce que tout le monde n'est pas n'a
pas vocation à aller en prison il y a
des peines qui parfois sont bien plus
efficaces le tige le travail d'intérêt
général par exemple qui permet dans
beaucoup de situations de casser le
petit tag de te délinquance dès le début
et puis de réinsérer quelqu'un il faut
pas avoir cette vision très dichotomique
de la prison voilà et un autre sujet
sans vouloir faire polémique les moyens
de la justice sous la période justement
avant Sarkozy et Sarkozy ont été la
variable d'ajustement et on se souvient
du plan de Rachida Dati qui était une
véritable saignée pour notre justice et
qu'on paye en partie aujourd'hui alors
il y a 15000 places de prison qui sont
prévues Cécile Hunter Maya est-ce que
pour vous c'est c'est nécessaire c'est
justifié comme le dit Erwan Balanant où
est-ce que c'est pas assez comme le dit
Olivier Marleix non je pense que le
problème il est pas là il faut être
pragmatique les 15000 places de prison
il faut qu'on les aie à un moment ou un
autre soit plus avaient dit 60000
détenus 73000 73000 détenus 60000 places
c'est mathématiques donc le sujet il est
pas là il est comment on réalise ces
places de prison et dans des délais qui
soient convenable le sujet il est là il
s'agit pas d'aller rajouter des places
de prison les accrocher après les 15000
parce que de toute façon il faut déjà
réaliser les 15000 mais l'objectif de
ressemble atteignable ou pas sur les pas
atteignable en 2027 je l'ai déjà dit
mais il y a des il y a des conditions il
y a des explications qui peuvent être
donnés par la majorité mais le résultat
est là on n'aura pas les 15000 places de
prison en 2027 on ne les aura pas mais
il faut effectivement
marcher dans cette voie ce que je
voulais dire aussi c'est que la justice
elle est pas vue uniquement à travers
les places de prison et le pénal la
justice c'est d'abord quand on a un
litige s'assurer effectivement que le
jugement va arriver et arriver vite et
cette façon de focaliser toute la
question de la justice sur la sécurité
elle pénale moi me gêne beaucoup parce
que le citoyen son sujet c'est pas le
nombre de places de prison son sujet
c'est que au prud'hommes quand il fait
quand il est tout prud'hommes il est pas
le jugement 4 ans après 4 ans après mais
ça peut aussi être une question de
sécurité pour les Français enfin la
question de sécurité ici on avait été
laxiste et là j'englobe bien sûr
de la justice il y a pas de laxiste
d'ailleurs si elle était laxiste et ben
il y aurait pas de surpopulation donc
c'est le sujet il est pas là il est
peut-être dans l'agilité qu'à la justice
pour répondre individuellement à des
questions de sécurité qui se posent et
pour avoir cette agilité il faut avoir
des effectifs il faut avoir des des
personnes qui sont autour de vous et qui
vous permettent d'avoir un certain recul
et d'être en capacité de rassembler les
éléments qui vous de donner des des des
des solutions qui sont pas
nécessairement l'enfermement en fait moi
j'ai envie de demander aux républicains
s'ils sont dans l'intention d'augmenter
les impôts de la France quoi ils savent
ce que représente un détenu en prison le
coup que cela représente pour la société
donc nous devons nous aussi et d'autant
plus que la récidive est massive donc on
est dans un dans un sujet à la fois
politique bien sûr sécurité économique
et sociétales alors il y a un article
dans ce projet de loi de justice qui
fait particulièrement débat c'est
l'article 3 sur la géolocalisation des
personnes visées et la captation de son
et d'image elles amont d'un Gava est-ce
que vous pouvez nous en dire un petit
peu plus oui c'est la possibilité
Brigitte d'activer à distance des
téléphones portables pour écouter et
filmer alors c'est dans le cas
d'affaires très sérieuses de crimes
organisé ou d'affaires de terroristes ça
pourrait concerner une dizaine
d'affaires par an a voulu rassurer le
garde des sceaux c'est le juge qui
pourra décider de mettre en place ces
dispositions
dans un temps limité et elle ne pourront
pas concerner certaines professions
comme les journalistes les magistrats et
les parlementaires tout ça se sont
présentés comme des garde-fous mais ça
ne rassure pas du côté de la nupes André
torignat pour vous vous êtes contre ce
dispositif en tant que tel oui
absolument parce que ce dispositif donc
existe en partie il est possible
aujourd'hui de géolocaliser des
téléphones portables donc qui
appartiennent à des individus suspects
mais là c'est une activation généralisée
sur un champ très large pour toutes les
peines d'au moins 5 ans et qui pourrait
aussi être comment dire mise en place
pour des terroristes et quand on voit
que le ministère de le ministre de
l'Intérieur
qualifie des terroristes les militants
politiques et qui combattent sur des
questions d'environnement de la planète
on peut on peut s'interroger et
s'inquiéter donc ce système de
surveillance généraliser ne nous ne nous
satisfait pas nous le combattons comme
le combat le Syndicat des Avocats de
France le Syndicat de la magistrature
petite dernière la Ligue la Ligue des
droits de l'Homme donc on est sur une
question de liberté fondamentale qu'on
rogne petit à petit et qui nous paraît
vraiment donner un mauvais signe d'une
dérive totalitaire petite question des
téléphones portables on en a tous un en
fait ils disent c'est le moyen de plus
simple finalement pour des enquêtes et
ce qu'il faut pas juste s'adapter aux
nouvelles technologies nous nous pensons
que le fait de s'adapter si ça doit
rogner sur les libertés fondamentales
nous ne sommes pas d'accord et en plus
dans cette loi il n'y a pas que les
téléphones portables il s'agit de tous
les objets connectés et tout peut être
enregistré le son l'image donc ça veut
dire que tous vos objets connectés
peuvent devenir des espions en à votre
insu et peuvent donc entrer dans votre
dans votre vie intime et tout peut être
ensuite en et voilà il y a au service de
qui au service de quoi surveillance
généralisé non on n'est pas d'accord on
touche à nos libertés fondamentales
merci beaucoup le projet de loi justice
est inscrit l'ordre du jour jusqu'à
jeudi soir et Juan Balanant je vous ai
entendu bondir là vous avez entendu
cette députés les filles elles disent
c'est une atteinte au droit fondamental
c'est une dérive totalitaire mais moi je
veux bien qu'on fasse peur aux Français
mais là je vais entendre des des bêtises
enfin je suis désolé je reste poli elle
vient de dire que c'est déjà possible
non c'est pas possible aujourd'hui le
juge ne peut pas utiliser la
géolocalisation premier point deuxième
point on va le rendre possible pour un
certain nombre d'affaires pour les pour
la justice non voilà c'est pas possible
on va le rendre ce qui est possible
c'est de géolocaliser soit avec un
bornage c'est-à-dire vous avez les trois
bornes vous mettez une borne pardon sur
la voiture par exemple soit par un
bornage avec trois antennes on sait mais
c'est pas précis on sait que ça marche
pas c'est compliqué
ce qu'on veut rendre possible c'est pour
les délits au dessus de 5 ans la
possibilité de géolocaliser ça peut
avoir des intérêts incroyables sur les
enlèvements d'enfants sur le suivi de du
proxénétisme sur tout un tas d'affaires
qui sont un des affaires qui sont de
moyenne intensité ensuite il y a un
deuxième sujet qui est le sujet des
écoutes par les téléphones portables
écoute et utilisation des caméras des
téléphones portables là on est sur de la
très haute intensité et ce qui s'appelle
les techniques spéciales d'enquête c'est
pour la criminalité organisée et c'est
pour le terrorisme on est très loin
d'une surveillance de masse on a vu les
juges d'instruction les juges
d'instruction sont quand même en
audition nous ont dit que que les gens
n'aient pas peur c'est une dizaine sauf
que les ONG beaucoup d'avocats aussi on
s'est mis des craintes et des garanties
que les garanties sur liberté
on a cette préoccupation moi je suis un
grand défendeur des libertés
individuelles mais là on est
l'utilisation très encadré avec des
délais qui sont des délais plus courts
que ce qui existe maintenant c'est un
jour avec l'autorisation d'un d'un
magistrat qui permet qui donne
l'autorisation ou non au procureur de
l'utiliser on a tout une série de
garde-fous après moi je partage et on en
a discuté un certain nombre de
préoccupations peut avoir madame Cécile
winter Mayer c'est sur le suivi de ces
mesures il va falloir qu'on les suive et
il va falloir que nous parlementaires
nous fassions notre travail d'évaluation
et de contrôle de l'action des pouvoirs
publics sur ces questions là mais on est
très très loin de la surveillance de
masse il faut et surtout il faut pas
dire n'importe quoi il faut pas faire
peur aux Français et juste pour conclure
les avocats avaient une crainte on a
réglé ses craintes par la destruction
des bandes de toutes les bandes qui
auraient été enregistrées dans des
conditions que l'on a défini impossible
aujourd'hui
est-ce que vous vous avez des réticences
aussi sur cet article 3 nous avons voté
contre l'article 3 je tiens à dire que
nous maintenons un vote contre l'article
3 qui a raison alors qu'il y a quand
même le l'inconvénient d'être
extrêmement
comment dire confus parce que on parle
de géolocalisation on parle de
perquisition on parle d'interprétariat
on parle de captation d'images si bien
que il y a des points sur lesquels on
peut être d'accord et sur d'autres on ne
l'est pas donc nous mon groupe a voté
contre l'article 3 et nous voterons
encore contre l'article 3 si c'était à
refaire mais alors pourquoi précisément
qu'est-ce qui vous fait peur nous
considérons non pas que c'est le
problème des libertés individuelles le
problème des je pense légitimes
effectivement que lorsqu'on cherche un
terroriste ou un grand criminel que la
justice comme la DGSE d'ailleurs pour la
sûreté de l'État dispose des moyens
d'investigation spéciale que permet ce
texte mais en revanche il faut des
garanties on sait très bien que la
qualification juridique qui permet
d'aller jusqu'à la captation il ne faut
pas qu'elle soit dévoyée et pour qu'elle
soit garantie il faut qu'on ait en face
du parquet il faut qu'on ait un JLD qui
soit extrêmement comment dire en juge
des libertés de la détention le juge des
libertés de la détention et moi je
milite vraiment pour que on conforte ce
dispositif il faut que le JLD quand il
est seul dans une juridiction il faut
savoir que c'est trop compliqué pour lui
pour faire face à une demande forte
alors dans des juridictions quand le JLD
est seul et bien il faut prévoir à 2027
le doublement de ces de ces de ces juges
spécialisés c'est une possibilité qui
est offerte que nous offre cette cette
manne financière qui arrive il me semble
que pour rassurer la population il faut
qu'il y ait un équilibre et c'est
équilibre entre le parquet et le JLD ne
doit pas être comment dire fragilisé
mais au contraire augmenter très
rapidement
le sait bien c'est sous autorisation du
JLD que pourra être donnée l'util de
cette technique spéciale d'enquête voilà
bon ensuite je le redis il s'agit pour
le son et pour l'image de de fait de
très hautes intensité des enquêtes
autour de la criminalité organisée
autour de terrorisme qui sont des
enquêtes la plupart du temps gérés par
les Gires qui sont des des juridictions
spécialisées sur ces questions là donc
franchement ne faisons pas peur aux
Français parce que ce sont des
techniques dont nos polices et nos
gendarmeries d'améliorer
d'attraper des gens qui sont par exemple
sur le très grand banditisme les
systèmes mafieux les systèmes
terroristes enfin c'est pas rien et
aujourd'hui ils sont beaucoup plus forts
que nous parce qu'ils utilisent déjà eux
ces techniques et ils savent les
détourner parfaitement il faut que nos
enquêteurs et les moyens de se mettre à
niveau on a compris que vous n'avez pas
voté cet article 3 pour autant est-ce
que vous allez voter l'ensemble du texte
écouter là le groupe va se prononcer
mais nous avons bien sûr des des
exigences
des rapports à cet article 3 qui passe
par le confortation du rôle du JLD alors
on me parle des Gires peut-être que
c'est dans ce cadre-là qu'on doit
trouver une solution mais il me semble
que le bon message serait au moment où
on ouvre un peu pour de bonnes raisons
les les techniques spéciales d'enquête
on doit dans le même temps renforcer le
rôle du JLD qui est le le juge des
libertés et réponse donc mardi prochain
pour ce vote solennelle sur le projet de
loi justice ils sont pas sa présence au
bruit de couloir dans cette émission
[Musique]
et on va retrouver Elsa mon Agava qui se
trouve ça le des quatre colonnes avec
cette information
LCP Elsa les trois présidents de groupe
de la majorité ont écrit ayaël Braun
Pivet il demande à ce que les députés
qui soient sont présents dans les
manifestations interdites soient
sanctionnées oui exactement Brigitte une
lettre signée donc par Aurore berger
pour Renaissance Jean-Paul Mattei du
modèle Laurent marquant Gélis pour
horizon lettre adressée à la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale Yale brune
Pivet vous l'avez dit pour demander des
sanctions financières contre les députés
présents à la manifestation organisée
par le comité vérité pour Adama du
prénom de ce jeune homme mort après une
interpellation il y a 7 ans dans le
Val-d'Oise une manifestation interdite
les trois groupes de la majorité
dénoncent donc la présence de députés de
la nupes avec leur écharpe tricolore et
la présence de slogans Antipolis alors
ces députés ils sont cités nommément
dans la lettre envoyée à la présidente
la majorité s'appuie sur un article du
règlement de l'Assemblée qui sanctionne
les députés qui se livrent à des
manifestations troubles en ordre oui
mais vous le savez normalement le
règlement de l'Assemblée il concerne les
comportements dans l'Assemblée nationale
c'est pas la première fois qui a
toutefois des demandes pour sanctionner
des députés qui vont à des
manifestations interdites en avril
dernier la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale avait envoyé un courrier à
tous les députés pour rappeler que le
comportement en dehors de l'hémicycle
était de leur responsabilité mais quand
même temps il était inconcevable que les
députés ne respectent pas les lois la
fonction parlementaire se trouve
dégradée lorsque l'écharpe tricolores
est porté à mauvais escient avait ajouté
la présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
il y a un bureau vous savez c'est
l'instance collégiale de décision de
l'assemblée qui se tient mercredi 19
juillet prochain cette question des
sanctions pourrait être soulevée elle
fera évidemment l'objet de vivre débat
politique entre la majorité et la
nupesse merci pour ces informations Elsa
mon hangar Byron Balanant ce courrier a
donc été signé par votre président de
groupe Jean-Paul Mattei comme Laurent
Marc angelipo horizon et Aurore berger
pour Renaissance qu'est-ce qu'il a
motivé est-ce qu'il faut aller plus loin
que ce qu'avait déjà écrit dans une
lettre la présidente moi je pense que il
y a il y a des trouble un peu tout le
monde cette présence la liberté de
manifester et constitutionnelle elle est
importante mais quand on est
parlementaire à des moments de troubles
et à des moments difficiles suite à un
moment où le pays a eu des émeutes c'est
à chacun d'appeler à la responsabilité
et je crois pas que c'était leur place
d'être à cette manifestation à ce
moment-là et donc vous souhaitez des
sanctions c'est ce qui est écrit dans le
courrier ça doit être mis à l'ordre du
jour pour vous du bureau mercredi
prochain moi je vais laisser le bureau
faire ses choix le bureau est souverain
des sanctions je sais pas mais que
chacun se pose un peu des questions et
ce se posent la question là de sa
responsabilité et du poids qui peut
avoir vis-à-vis de jeunes vis-à-vis de
gens qui aujourd'hui dans un trouble
parfois qui peut être compréhensible
suite à cette à ce décès dramatique de
cet enfant je crois qu'il faut appeler
au calme et appeler plutôt à essayer de
trouver des solutions dans le dans le
j'ai envie de dire dans une sérénité
nécessaire et je ne suis pas sûr qu'elle
est à des manifestations interdites soit
la meilleure des réponses mais je le
redis et ça c'est une conviction forte
que j'ai le droit de manifester dans
notre pays est constitutionnel
Cécile Hunter Mayer le PS n'était pas
présent sauf erreur de ma part à cette
manifestation pour Adama Traoré
ça veut dire que vous vous désolidarisez
finalement de la France insoumise qui
était où les écologistes c'est pas pour
autant que les sanctionner
je suis je suis je suis hostile par
principe à sanctionner un député parce
que à l'extérieur il a considéré en
conscience qu'il devait faire telle
chose ou telle chose c'est la place des
députés où dans des manifestations comme
ça il y avait aussi des manifestants qui
chantaient moi je déteste la police
en responsabilité des députés
choisissent d'y aller ils y vont
finalement le grand comptable c'est les
lecteurs donc moi je crois que toute qui
viennent entre les lecteurs et le député
sont des strates qui sont dangereuses
donc pour pour ma part je considère
qu'on a mieux à faire à l'Assemblée
nationale que d'aller encore
cristalliser des situations alors même
que les citoyens attendent de nous
beaucoup en ce moment est-ce qu'on est
dans le champ républicain quand tout le
monde déteste la police et chanté dans
une manifestation et que ben on exprimer
rien finalement on ne quitte pas cette
manifestation moi je suis pas téléguidée
non plus par ces dispositifs je sais pas
quel a été le comportement des députés à
l'intérieur même de ces manifestations
j'ai pas le sentiment qu'ils aient eu un
comportement qui trouble l'ordre public
voilà c'est accordé beaucoup trop
d'importance me semble-t-il aux députés
que de considérer que parce qu'ils
participent à une manifestation il en
entache ou il en embellit le dispositif
je crois qu'il faut revenir à la
responsabilité du député qui fait ce que
bon lui semble il connaît les lois comme
nous il connaît les risques mais c'est
pas me semble-t-il au bureau de
s'arroger un pouvoir de sanction
par rapport à des députés qui ont
considéré utiles en conscience de devoir
participer à cette manifestation sinon
où va-t-on on passe à présent au focus
dans cette émission
[Musique]
et je vous remercie évidemment d'avoir
participé à ce débat on va s'arrêter
rester avec moi deux petites secondes on
va s'arrêter sur la proposition de loi
du député horizon du Nord Paul
Christophe visant à améliorer
l'accompagnement des familles d'enfants
handicapés ou souffrant de pathologies
chroniques un accord a été trouvé la
semaine dernière en commission mixte
paritaire et le texte devrait
définitivement être adopté demain Paul
Christophe bonjour alors votre
proposition de loi sera adoptée donc
définitivement demain elle veut
simplifier la vie des familles qui ont
des enfants handicapés expliquez-nous
quels sont les principales mesures oui
bonjour c'est une loi qu'on pourrait
résumer en trois axes un premier qui
vise à mieux protéger finalement les les
familles de parents d'enfants gravement
malade ou victimes de handicap notamment
vis-à-vis des questions d'emplois
vis-à-vis des questions de logement en
particulier elle vise finalement aussi à
accélérer la réponse qu'on peut apporter
et la rendre plus compatible avec les
attentes je pense en particulier au
délai d'instruction du congé de présence
parental qui aujourd'hui prend quasiment
trois mois alors que c'est une procédure
d'urgence avec cette loi en permettra
d'apporter une réponse satisfaisante
sous 15 jours elle vise aussi finalement
améliorer la réponse notamment sur ce
qu'on appelle le congé d'annonce lorsque
la pathologie est diagnostiquée
aujourd'hui il était de deux jours elle
sera demain de 5 jours et
malheureusement lorsque l'issue est
fatal à le congé deuil qui se rapportait
à 14 jours pour un enfant de moins de 25
ans et 12 jours pour les plus de 25 ans
et enfin il y a un troisième volet qui
est important également qui vise
finalement à adapter à les réponses
d'une manière nouvelle avec une
expérimentation proposée à l'aune des
caves qui permettra de finalement de se
pencher sur la relation avec les
travailleurs sociaux mais aussi sur
comment mieux prendre en charge les
transports lorsque l'enfant n'est pas
dans le véhicule qu'il faut retourner
s'occuper de la fratrie comment mieux
accompagner dans la famille en termes de
logements lorsque le centre d'encologie
par exemple pédiatrique est éloigné du
domicile et qu'il faut prévoir
finalement une hospitalisation longue et
la présence d'un parent bien évidemment
à ses côtés donc il y a tout un volet
d'accompagnement au quotidien c'est ça
en dehors de ces périodes de congés tout
à fait c'est protégé c'est accompagné je
pense que l'idée générale c'est de faire
en sorte que les parents et à se
consacrer sur ce qui n'est pas le plus
simple c'est l'accompagnement des soins
prodigués à l'enfant en vue de sa
guérison donc il nous faut finalement
dépolluer tout cet environnement que ce
soit travail logement finance pour faire
en sorte que les parents et pour seul
souci celui de la santé de l'enfant vous
avez presque battu un record 5 mois
entre le moment où elle proposition de
la discuté pour la première fois et où
est l'état d'optée comment ça s'explique
vous aviez le soutien complet du
gouvernement c'est la conclusion comme
d'un travail que j'ai entamé sous le
mandat précédent on me reconnaît une
vraie légitimité à travailler sur le
champ des aidants mais ceci est un vrai
plaisir pour moi de recueillir
finalement l'unanimité tant à
l'Assemblée nationale qu'au Sénat ce qui
prouve sur des sujets de société
où on fait preuve d'humanisme on sait se
rassembler travailler tous ensemble pour
améliorer la situation des personnes
concernées merci beaucoup et je rappelle
votre définitive de votre proposition de
loi demain
et si vous nous rejoignez sur LCP sachez
que nous sommes à 25 minutes à présent
des questions au Gouvernement vous allez
pouvoir suivre en direct et en
intégralité sur LCP vous le voyez la
Garde Républicaine vient de s'installer
derrière moi les tambours sont prêts à
la revue des troupes va avoir lieu dans
quelques instants il jouera en tout cas
du tambour à l'arrivée de la présidente
de l'Assemblée nationale nous vous
ferons vivre cette événement se
cérémonial en direct ce sera juste avant
15h pour présider la séance de questions
au gouvernement dans cette émission vous
retrouverez comme d'habitude elles a mon
Agava et Stéphanie Despierre qui se
trouve celle des quatre colonnes pour
toutes les réactions politiques nous
retrouvons bien sûr Marco pommier dans
les mystique de l'Assemblée nationale
pour les questions au Gouvernement et
puis nous vous ferons vivre l'arrivée
des membres du gouvernement de la
première ministre Elisabeth borne ce
sera juste avant la séance aux alentours
de 14h50 et ce sera cours d'honneur
l'entrée principale du palais Bourbon
trouve tout de suite Marco pommier qui
lui est donc dans l'hémicycle de
l'Assemblée nationale Marco quel est le
thème est-ce qu'il y a un thème qui se
dégage aujourd'hui de cette séance de
questions
plusieurs sujets à un préoccupe les
députés Brigitte avec d’abord
l'influence à des réseaux sociaux dans
la propagation à des violences urbaines
fin juin la semaine dernière Emmanuel
Macron avait évoqué l'idée de couper ses
plateformes en cas de tension autre
sujet la manifestation du week-end
dernier en mémoire d'Adama Traoré samedi
2000 personnes se sont rassemblées à
Paris dont plusieurs députés de la
France insoumise et des écologistes
malgré l'interdiction de la préfecture
de police trois questions sur le sujet
les insoumis justement interpelleront le
gouvernement sur la braven cette unité
de police Anne moto de nouveau mise en
cause pour des violences excusez-moi
pour des violences en marge se
rassemblement une enquête administrative
a été ouverte est-ce qu'il y aura
d'autres questions qui seront également
déborder Marco cet après-midi
oui Brigitte on parlera aussi du recours
de l'État au cabinet de conseils dans un
rapport publié hier la Cour des comptes
pointe les rôles des recours
inappropriés au consultant privé les
magistrats appellent l'état mieux
maîtriser cette pratique malgré quelques
progrès au moins trois questions cet
après-midi sur le sujet et puis à noter
cette question des républicains à Papen
DIY concernant l'une de ces déclarations
dimanche sur Radio J le ministre de
l'éducation nationale affirmait que
cnews et Europe 1 était très clairement
d'extrême droite de médias qui font du
mal à la démocratie a-t-il dit de quoi
susciter l'indignation des républicains
et du rassemblement national merci Marco
pour ce menu complet des questions au
Gouvernement je vous présente à présent
mes invités pour cette deuxième partie
de questions d'actu on va retrouver
Charles Simpson stool bonjour et
bienvenue merci d'être avec nous vous
êtes députés renaissance du Bas-Rhin et
Sébastien Jumel bonjour bienvenue à vous
vous êtes député GDR communiste de
Seine-Maritime alors vous le savez sur
LCP on s'intéresse aussi aux questions
des citoyens s'ils étaient dans
l'hémicycle cet après-midi à la place
des députés quelle question et bien il
poserait aux membres du gouvernement
alors je vous propose d'entendre
Véronique qui vit dans les
Alpes-Maritimes bonjour je m'appelle
Véronique je viens de Nice
je suis propriétaire et dans mon
logement je propose un appartement en
location saisonnière j'ai une question à
poser au ministre du Logement
je souhaiterais qu'il y ait une
réglementation au niveau des locations
saisonnières de type Airbnb pour que
l'on puisse proposer un logement
uniquement dans sa résidence principale
donc pour une durée de 120 jours ce qui
me paraît à peu près honnête mais que
les personnes n'en fassent pas un
business et puis se proposer à la
location plusieurs
logements ce qui finalement va pénaliser
les hôteliers qui ont d'autres taxes et
d'autres charges voilà je vous remercie
qu'est-ce que vous pensez de cette
question de Véronique est-ce
qu'effectivement il faudrait que la
possibilité de louer 120 jours par an là
en Airbnb soit réservé à la résidence
principale la question elle est légitime
parce qu'en fait Airbnb c'est toutes les
questions que posent la nouvelle
économie numérique c'est plateformes
avec qui permettent notamment à des
personnes qui sont pas forcément des
entreprises de mettre en location là on
l'espèce des logements alors déjà il y a
une loi en 2018 la loi Elan qui a
introduit dans notre droit la limitation
à 120 jours par an il y a 18 communes 18
grands villes en France qui vont se
saisir de cette opportunité c'est donc
c'est déjà un cas très concret de
réglementation on verra les effets que
ça aura et ce qu'il faudra encore durcir
à l'avenir probablement moi je suis pas
opposé vous trouvez qu'il y a un
business Sébastien jumelles autour de la
location d'appartements autour des
Airbnb oui c'est devenu la folie sur le
littoral à Saint-Malo à Dieppe dans ma
ville on constate une explosion
de ce type de location avec un double
effet kiss cool d'abord on ampute des
logements qui étaient destinés à pouvoir
offrir des capacités d'accueil pour les
habitants du territoire sa pénalise
d'une manière déloyale les hébergements
touristiques les hôtels notamment et
puis ça peut si on n'y prend pas garde
vider les coeurs de ville de leur
vitalité ce qui fait que Dieppe est la
plus belle ville du monde c'est qu'elle
est vivante tout le temps
et donc qui a besoin de légiférer il y a
besoin de leviers fiscaux pour pénaliser
ceux qui font du business d'une certaine
manière sur le dos du droit au logement
et puis il y a des zones tendues où ça
devient l'enfer et donc il faut être à
l'écoute des mères qui ont des
propositions très pertinentes à formuler
pour faire évoluer la législation
d'ailleurs la question du logement du
logement social va être à la rentrée à
ne pas douter la question de
préoccupation majeure de nos concitoyens
retour à présent donc aux questions au
Gouvernement posé par les députés on va
prendre une question du député les
républicains de la Manche Philippe
Gosselin qu'on va retrouver au micro
d'Elsa mandingava il compte interpeller
le gouvernement et notamment sur les
propos tenus par Pape and dye c'était ce
week-end à l'encontre de cnews et de
Europe 1 dont l'actionnaire est Vincent
Bolloré oui le ministre de l'éducation
qui a qualifié ces deux médias de médias
d'extrême droite pour vous il est allé
trop loin ça vous choque on attend du
ministre de l'éducation qui se préoccupe
davantage des questions d'éducation il y
a des sujets sur la laïcité sur le
harcèlement scolaire sur l'apprentissage
des fondamentaux de quel droit ces
riches t-il en senseur de la
bien-pensance et en général c'est
toujours à sens unique ces choses là
donc voilà on veut le rappeler à ses
obligations à son ministère à son poste
il y a tant à faire en sujet d'urgence
qu'il ferait mieux de se focaliser
là-dessus sont une dérive droitière
c'est ce qui est pourtant a pu être
dénoncé certains anciens salariés à
cnews à Europe 1 et c'est le cas des
salariés du JDD en ce moment est-ce que
vous n'écoutez pas vous n'entendez pas
aussi cet argument non mais c'est pas au
ministre de l'éducation nationale d'être
le censeur de la bien-pensance de la
ligne éditoriale de telle ou tel journal
est-ce qu'on l'entend sur l'humain sur
Libé sur tel ou tel revue Hebdo et non
et à juste titre ça fait partie de la
complémentarité de la
pluridisciplinarité de de la différence
qui peut exister dans nos démocraties
point barre merci point barre merci
beaucoup on est écoutera votre question
et la réponse dans les disciples
Sébastien jumelles vous avez entendu
Philippe Gosselin est-ce que pour vous
comme le disait papa Ndiaye c'est deux
médias font du mal à la démocratie et
sont clairement d'extrême droite non
mais je note comme vous que d'abord la
solidarité du gouvernement à l'égard du
ministre de l'éducation nationale a été
aux abonnés absents il est seul dans
l'affirmation d'une vérité que tout le
monde mesure il y a une concentration
des médias dans la main de quelques-uns
et ces quelques-uns ont des arrières
pensées politiques pour faire prévaloir
je veux dire dans la perspective des
élections présidentielles futures un
choix qui n'est pas y compris celui de
la République donc il y a danger alors
dans ce que dit
vous vous trouvez que c'est normal ça
finisse de l'éducation nationale
tiennent ce discours une chose est juste
dans ce que dit Philippe Gosselin
c'est-à-dire qu'on attend du ministre de
l'éducation nationale qui se préoccupe
des non fermetures de classe de l'avenir
de nos enfants d'augmenter les besoins
de formation là il y en besoins mais il
est pas illégitime qu'à un membre du
gouvernement tire la sonnette et y
compris peut-être du ministre de la
Culture qui a cette compétence sur le
sérieux problème de la concentration des
pouvoirs dont vous risquez vous-même
comme journaliste d'être victime si on
n'y prend pas garde alors nous on est
public mais on sait jamais on ne sait
jamais comme vous dites
Charles Simpson est-ce que c'est le rôle
effectivement du ministre de l'Éducation
de tenir ce genre de propos on a entendu
Laurence Ferrari qui elle travaille
justement pour Vincent Bolloré dire
finalement que ça insulte l'ensemble des
journalistes de ces rédactions est-ce
que c'est justifié tenir des propos
comme ça moi je suis bien embêté parce
que les propos du ministre me dérangent
voilà je le dis de façon très
transparente tout en étant de la
majorité présidentielle je pense que les
responsables politiques de façon
générale
doivent être économe de leurs propos
dans le commentaire qui est fait des il
y a une pluralité des médias dans notre
pays il y a des lignes éditoriales moi
j'ai eu l'occasion notamment d'aller sur
cnews sur Europe 1 j'ai constaté que il
y avait des journalistes des
présentateurs qui avaient des
sensibilités des fibres différentes
alors il y a une ligne éditoriale
général
comme il y a des lignes éditoriales dans
d'autres médias et moi ces propos je les
trouve voilà un peu un peu inapproprié
et je pense que quand on est responsable
politique en tout cas moi c'est comme ça
que j'ai appris la politique il y a
quelques années
on ne commente pas trop ce qui se passe
dans les médias les médias on leur vie
la vie politique à sa vie et pas
d'inquiétude pour le pluralisme de la
presse pas particulièrement en tout cas
de la presse dans notre pays je veux
dire ce qui se passe aujourd'hui Journal
du Dimanche nous préoccupe et occupe
évidemment
et c'était effectivement à l'occasion de
la grève
au
Journal du Dimanche autre question à
présent qui sera imposée cet après-midi
dans l'hémicycle de l'Assemblée
nationale sur l'arc républicain alors
que la première ministre a dit que la
France insoumise était sortie du champ
républicain en appelant pas au calme
après la mort de Naël question de
Marianne Maximy députée la France
insoumise du Puy-de-Dôme elle est à
votre micro Stéphanie Despierre bonjour
Marianne Maximy qu'est-ce que vous allez
demander précisément au gouvernement
bonjour écoutez moi je vais interroger
la première ministre sur qu'est-il que
s'est-il passé avec cet arc républicain
entre l'élection présidentielle où il
fallait faire barrage à l'extrême droite
aller chercher les électeurs de gauche
et aujourd'hui ou la gauche serait
exclue de cet arc républicain donc je
vais interroger le gouvernement sur ces
récentes déclarations qui nous
concernent qui nous inquiète parce que
nous exclure de la récupérer républicain
c'est évidemment il fait rentrer le
rassemblement national ces idées
racistes et le danger qu'il représente
pour notre pays
qu'est-ce que vous reprochez très
précisément au gouvernement ces derniers
jours ces dernières semaines ce qu'on
reproche au gouvernement c'est de
choisir son opposition la plus
confortable il se trouve que le
rassemblement national semble l'être
tout simplement parce qu'il ne va pas
questionner les questions libérales du
gouvernement parce que le rassemblement
national est une arnaque sociale qui
valide toute la politique néolibérale du
gouvernement et que nous l'opposition de
la nuit pêche justement on est une
alternative politique crédible à cette
politique là donc il faut un choix qui
est éminemment dangereux pour l'avenir
de notre pays pour la montée du racisme
on voit déclaration après déclaration
dans les médias notamment du côté des
républicains mais pas que
on sait aussi que la position de la
France insoumise et de Jean-Luc
Mélenchon pendant les émeutes de ne pas
appeler au calme a été très critiqué en
interne du côté de la nupesse ça va
laisser les traces c'est du débat entre
nous mais en tout cas la position de la
France insoumise a toujours été
d'appeler à la justice de créer les
conditions pour un calme durable je le
répète appelé au calme si c'est pour que
dans 6 mois nous ayons exactement les
mêmes événements ce n'est pas une
responsabilité politique en tout cas
qu'on veut avoir nous nous voulons des
conditions durables du calme nous
voulons la justice nous voulons pouvoir
avoir des propositions politiques que
nous avons mis sur la table maintenant
nous attendons que le gouvernement
travaille et pour l'instant en temps au
niveau de l'apaisement nous n'avons rien
entendu et en termes de proposition pour
l'instant c'est zéro aussi merci je vous
laisse rejoindre les missiles pour cette
séance de questions au gouvernement
vous avez entendu cette députée la
première ministre a dit effectivement
que la France insoumise était hors du
champ républicain elle elle dit vous
avez choisi votre opposition et vous
tapez sur lf6 ça fait monter le
rassemblement
nationalitions
lors des élections législatives de juin
2022 ça fait également un an que la
première ministre et la majorité a fixé
les règles du jeu pour nous dire nous
considérons que nous travaillons avec
tous les groupes politiques à
l'Assemblée nationale à l'exception du
groupe d'extrême gauche qui est la
France insoumise et du groupe d'extrême
droite qui est le rassemblement national
et c'est un langage constant que nous
avons depuis un an quant au comportement
de la France insoumise depuis au cours
de ces derniers mois enfin c'est
eux-mêmes qui ne cesse de se tirer des
balles dans le pied Jean-Luc Mélenchon
qui appelle à abattre la République
Jean-Luc Mélenchon et ses députés qui
rajoutent de l'huile sur le feu il y a
deux semaines lors des émeutes c'est
eux-mêmes qui ont fait leur propre
erreurs pompier Pyroman alors du côté de
la France insoumise qu'est-ce que vous
en pensez vous Sébastien Jumel vous êtes
proche de la France insoumise vous êtes
dans le dans la nuque mais vous êtes au
parti communiste finalement est-ce que
vous diriez que les filles est sortie du
champ républicain en appelant pas au
calme sur les émeutes urbaines je vous
invite à réfléchir avec moi sur une
chose simple qu'est-ce qui fait
République
ce sont les services publics ce sont les
solidarités concrètes c'est notre modèle
de protection sociale à la française
c'est le fait que quel que soit
l'endroit où on habite on puisse avoir
accès au logement à l'emploi aux
mobilité au droit à la santé à égalité
c'est le consentement à l'impôt qui fait
République il est quand même un peu
particulier que ceux qui passent leur
temps le gouvernement la majorité a
abusé cela distribue des brevets
de de bonnes séances républicaines alors
moi je veux acter devant vous qu'il y a
au sein de la gauche des différences et
même quelquefois il existe des
divergences notamment dans la période
récente sur la manière à condamné le
fait que Jean-Luc Mélenchon
je suis député
j'imagine que vous êtes des camarades
[Musique]
mais moi je considère que les insoumis
font partie du bloc républicain
d'ailleurs je constate que il y a une
difficulté pour les marcheurs à
considérer qu'ils en font partie au
moment des présidentielles à la veille
du second tour et a décrété qu'ils n'en
font plus partie un an après lorsque des
divergences les opposent notre
responsabilité à nous à gauche c'est de
surmonter nos différences de dialoguer
en franchise et sereinement sur y
compris des différences d'appréciations
qu'on a sur des questions
très clairement et moi je n'étais pas
d'accord avec la manière de réagir sur
par exemple des émeutes je pense qu'il
fallait s'aligner sur la sagesse des
mers et les mers ont été profondément
responsables dans ce qui s'est passé
mais moi je considère que les insoumis
sont dans l'arc républicain qu'il
n'appartient pas au libéraux de
distribuer des mauvais points et qu'il y
a un danger que de choisir ses
oppositions en démocratie on ne choisit
pas ses opposants alors vous avez
entendu la sonnerie mes rassurez-vous un
Sébastien jumelles vous avez été entendu
parler
je n'entendais pas ce que je disais
qu'on nous sommes effectivement à 10
minutes de la de la séance de questions
au Gouvernement Charles zittenhtool il y
a aussi la présence à la manifestation
de ce week-end d'Adama Traoré
manifestation interdites et il y avait
la présence de députés de la France
insoumise de députés écologistes est-ce
que ça mérite finalement des des
sanctions de la part de l'Assemblée
nationale puisqu'on sait que votre
présidente de groupe tous les présidents
des groupes de la majorité l'ont demandé
il y a le One Pivet
ça ça sera au bureau de l'Assemblée de
statuer en revanche c'est profondément
choquant mais pour des raisons là aussi
très très simples les parlementaires
quel que soit leur couleur politique ils
sont là pour faire la loi pour voter la
loi donc quelle contradiction pour nous
concitoyens que de voir que les gens qui
font la loi ne respectent pas la loi
c'est ça qui est choquant dans la
démarche pour certains parlementaires de
la France insoumise et d'Europe Écologie
Les Verts à se rendre à une
manifestation qui est interdite pas qui
est interdite
c'est faux le fait de se d'aller à une
manifestation qui n'est qui est
interdite et passible et passive d'une
sanction et le fait que cette
manifestation a été interdite c'est pas
le fait du prince
le matin c'est parce que ça a été basé
sur la législation française sur notre
corpus juridique c'est la même affaire
que pour sainte Soline c'est à dire à
Sainte-Souline vous avez des
parlementaires d'extrême gauche ou
encore une fois écologiste qui vont au
devant des forces de l'ordre qui vont
provoquer les forces de l'ordre c'est
profondément choquant en plus quand
c'est fait avec une écharpe bleu blanc
rouge autour du cou Sébastien jumelles
effectivement ils avaient leur écharpe
autour du cou c'est la place des députés
finalement d'être présent dans une
manifestation interdite
d'abord est-ce qu'on peut limiter le
droit d'expression d'un parlementaire le
droit de participer à une initiative le
droit de manifester on la réponse à
cette question est non on ne peut pas
limiter il n'appartient pas à la
présidente de l'Assemblée nationale
d'être la police de la morale ou la
police tout
courts de sanctionner un parlementaire
ce sont en démocratie les électeurs
ensuite il y a la question de
l'opportunité de participer à cette
manive nous n'avons pas participé à
cette manifestation non pas que le
combat mené par la famille ne sois pas
légitime mais nous nous pensions que le
contexte
récent ne permettait pas une
manifestation sereine cela dit elle
s'est déroulée
semble-t-il parfaitement mais moi je
vous mets en garde si on démocratie on
commence à vouloir encadrer la liberté
d'agir de voter de s'exprimer de bouger
des parlementaires ça ne s'appelle plus
la démocratie j'ajoute que et je prends
la précautionatoire de dire que la
comparaison n'est pas un anachronisme
historique mais que dans l'histoire de
France il est des moments où les
parlementaires ont des obéi et peut-être
sommes-nous heureux qu'ils aient
désobéis c'est peut-être pour ça que
vous êtes ici à l'Assemblée nationale
aujourd'hui les émeutes ont été
largement nourri les émeutes urbaines de
ces derniers jours par les messageries
instantanées ou les jeunes se relayaient
un certain nombre d'informations pour
participer à ses émeutes Isabelle
rochequet député horizon et apparentée
de la Moselle posera une question cet
après-midi je vous propose de l'écouter
au micro d'Elsa moringava oui vous vous
intéressez justement à ces réseaux
sociaux qui ont eu un rôle dans les
émeutes qu'est-ce que vous vous voulez
mieux réguler
alors moi ce que je veux c'est que en
situation d'urgence on puisse vraiment
très rapidement retirer tous les
contenus qui appellent à la haine en
fait tous les contenus illicites parce
que comme vous le dites on a vu que
pendant les émeutes ça a vraiment joué
un rôle énorme et que en fait il y a eu
un entraînement dans ces bulles
informationnelles donc c'est aussi quel
transparence on a sur ces algorithmes
qui font qu'à un moment donné on a
l'impression que la France est embrasée
de partout que voilà on va on va voir
tout le temps tout le temps tout le
temps la même chose et c'est extrêmement
dangereux et à ce moment-là il faut que
on puisse stopper cette machine et faire
comprendre aux uns aux autres que
l'importance aussi c'est finalement de
retrouver une hygiène numérique ensuite
est-ce que vous souhaitez comme on a pu
l'entendre couper les réseaux sociaux
dans certains quartiers par exemple un
soir d'émeutes alors ça je pense que
c'est pas c'est pas forcément la bonne
solution moi ce que je suis c'est pour
que on remette en fait les parents aussi
au cœur du système et que chacun et
chacune apprennent comme je vous le
disais apprendre du recul après à se
servir des outils numériques et que avec
cela on puisse en effet avoir une action
concertée et cohérente sur sur ses
embrasements algorithmiques qui font
ensuite des embrasements au sens propre
dans les quartiers et pas que dans les
quartiers d'ailleurs dans la France
entière ça passe du virtuel à la vie
réelle merci on entendra le ministre de
la transition numérique qui a rencontré
les plateformes à de nombreuses reprises
ces derniers jours Charles instant
school Emmanuel Macron s'est prononcé en
faveur d'un blocage ponctuel et
temporaire des réseaux sociaux lorsque
la situation l'exigerait il y a pas
atteinte à la liberté non parce que
c'est vrai ce serait vraiment dans des
cas extrêmes d'ailleurs il faut encore
qu'on étudie ça simplement
internet c'est un formidable espace de
liberté comme tout espace où il y a
beaucoup de liberté il peut aussi y
avoir des dangers donc il faut que les
plateformes appliquent aussi leurs
obligations d'ordre public les
plateformes vous êtes d'accord elles
doivent jouer davantage le jeu elles
doivent supprimer ces messages quand
elle les voit passer s'il y a
effectivement un danger pour la nation
la République était suffisamment balade
pour envisager des mesures de style
c'est vraiment qu'elle va pas bien pour
le reste en période de crise ou hors
période de crise il serait juste que les
réseaux sociaux assurent une régulation
pour éviter les propos homophobes
d'incitation la haine de propos racistes
ou xénophobe c'est en période de crise
comme en milieu ordinaire nécessaire
merci à tous les deux d'avoir participé
à cette deuxième partie de questions
d'actu
Stéphanie Despierres pour le menu des
questions au gouvernement puisque nous
sommes à un peu plus de deux minutes
maintenant de cette séance c'est Fanny
alors il y a des thèmes assez différents
la semaine dernière tout portait sur les
émeutes et bien cette semaine les thèmes
sont beaucoup plus variés même si vous
l'avez dit tout à l'heure on parlera
quand même des émeutes et notamment de
l'influence des réseaux sociaux sur les
pillages et les violences il y a trois
questions sur ce sujet et puis on
parlera également de la manifestation de
samedi en hommage à Adama Traoré vous le
savez manifestation qui était interdite
2000 personnes s'ils sont rendues dont
des députés de la France insoumise et
puis il y a également des questions sur
les recours au cabinet de conseil par le
gouvernement par les ministères pour
diriger pour décider de l'action
publique après un rapport au vitriol de
la Cour des comptes
merci Stéphanie Despierre pour ce menu
complet des questions au Gouvernement
ces questions vont démarrer dans une
minute trente environ maintenant moi je
me trouve effectivement dans la salle
juste attenante à la salle des quatre
colonnes qui est la salle des pas perdus
et c'est ici derrière moi que la Garde
Républicaine voyez est installée la
garde républicaine qui va jouer du
tambour c'est le cérémonial habituel au
passage de la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale il y a El Brown pivel va
arriver dans dans une minute maintenant
sous les tambours de la Garde
Républicaine il y a aussi beaucoup de
citoyens qui sont là qui sont venus
assister à cette séance de questions au
gouvernement et à ce petit événement ici
à l'Assemblée nationale l'arrivée de la
présidente moment toujours assez
solennel Elsa mon Agava qu'elle est
ambiance de votre côté et bien écoutez
ici salle des quatre colonnes on assiste
aux dernières interviews de députés on
peut voir Guillaume kessbaland pour la
majorité Erwan baleine qui était il y a
quelques minutes sur notre plateau
Nicolas Dupont-Aignan Philippe Gosselin
alors on parle beaucoup ici de la lettre
c'était une information de la Chaîne
Parlementaire la lettre envoyée par les
trois présidents de groupe pour demander
des sanctions contre les députés qui ont
participé à une manifestation interdite
en la mémoire d'Adama Traoré il y aura
plusieurs questions sur le sujet dans
l'hémicycle et puis ce sujet il va se
réinviter au fil des prochains jours à
l'Assemblée puisque des députés de la
majorité vont demander des sanctions ils
vont sûrement le formuler lors du bureau
vous savez c'est la Réunion collégiale
qui détermine les sanctions les
décisions de l'Assemblée nationale il
aura lieu le mercredi 19 juillet
prochain merci Elsa mon Agava pour pour
toutes ces précisions effectivement un
courrier qui a été signé par les trois
présidents de groupe de la majorité pour
sanctionner les députés qui étaient
présents assez manifestations et ce
courrier finalement donnait les noms des
députés présents on verra en tout cas si
la semaine prochaine le bureau
sanctionne ou non ces députés de la
France insoumise et du côté des
écologistes la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale va arriver dans quelques
instants elle va traverser cette salle
des papas
[Musique]
voilà la présidente de l'Assemblée
nationale qui vient de traverser cette
salle des pas perdue et qui rejoint
actuellement l'émission de l'Assemblée
nationale elle monte au perchoir pour
présider cette séance de questions au
gouvernement où on va revenir sur la
manifestation interdite pour Adama
Traoré sur l'influence des réseaux
sociaux dans les émotures ben ou sur la
dissolution de la bravème très bonne
séance à tous
[Musique]